cricket
a quiet sport
[Applause]
pioneered by the British
[Applause]
measured
considered
timeless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just a couple of decades ago cricket was
struggling to attract audiences and its
commercial future was very much in doubt
now it has the second biggest sporting
franchise in the world bettered only by
the NFL
at the center of its success is one
country and its record-breaking
tournament
the Indian Premier League
so there's been a revolution in cricket
traditionally what used to happen when
English Cricket started cricket and the
rest of the world stopped now such is
the glamor of IPL such are the richest
IPL provides that English Cricket has to
bow down to India
there are 74 games now in the IPL and
each one is valued at over 10 million
pounds for one game there's no way that
other formats of the game before could
have commanded that sort of financial
power or value the figures that I talked
about is that 80 percent of world
Cricket's income is provided by India in
one form or the other India currently
has a population of 1.4 billion people
IPL has a viewership of almost 700
million people
worldwide fan base for Cricket is about
two and a half billion people we are 27
percent of that total fan base worldwide
so potential to grow this viewership
immense massive
this is the story of how one country
became the driving force behind the
biggest sporting turnaround of the 21st
Century
[Music]
well Cricket is this unique English game
the English invented most of the sports
but Cricket is probably unique in that
the two sets of players are doing
opposite things one of them is playing
with a bat and the other one is playing
with the ball
it's one of those kind of quite
enigmatic Sports to describe I think
it's the battle between runs the number
of runs you can score versus the number
of wickets and a wicket is when a batter
gets out so it's a contest between runs
and wickets
the overall aim of the game is to score
more runs than the opposing team
a run is essentially a point and it's
given every time a batter runs between
the wickets which is possible after the
ball has been bowled
four runs are given if the batsman hits
the ball beyond the boundary of the
pitch with the ball having hit the
ground
six is given for batters who can clear
the boundary without the ball hitting
the ground
the Fielding team bowls to the batting
team a field of bowls and sets of six
balls which are called an over after
each over the bowler changes the best
way to prevent the batting team from
scoring is by getting the batsman out or
taking wickets this can be done in many
ways bowling catching or running out
once 10 of the 11 batsmen are out their
Innings finishes and they can't score
any more runs the same is true if they
run out of time which varies depending
on the type of cricket game and is where
the most revolution has taken place in
recent years
its most traditional format is multi-day
Cricket so where it's played with a red
ball and there are three results
possible Win Lose or Draw so I know
people are completely stumped by the
fact that you can play a game for five
days and still draw at the end of it
crickets complicated rules and Long play
time meant it struggled to appeal to
fans outside commonwealth countries who
are deeply historical ties to the game
invented in England in the 1600s Cricket
arrived in other parts of the globe
during the late 17th and 18th centuries
via British colonizers
the British took the game to different
parts of the world as they expanded as
they went in search of trade and then
they acquired territories they didn't
tell people you have to play our sport
they played their Sport and the other
people seeing the British play the sport
was attracted by it while a number of
the commonwealth countries adopted the
game as their own one managed to turn
the sport into big business
I think the Indians who've been given no
chance at all I'd liked it to give a
great deal More Travel than many people
expect
when I was a very young boy that was a
long time ago in the 50s as a
five-year-old I was taken in India in
Mumbai to watch England play India
Bose the BBC's first sports news editor
is one of Cricket's best known
commentators his most recent book nine
waves the extraordinary story of how
India took over the Cricket World traces
the country's rise from Colonial
dependency to Global dominance within
the sport the money in Cricket came
through and this was worldwide came
through people at the gates buying
tickets when a team came over in England
Australia West Indies New Zealand or
whoever there would be in the cities
what was called test fever people would
want to buy tickets they would be long
queues to get tickets and so on and and
that was the situation till well into
the 1990s
television had shown its potential in
India during the 1982 Asian games but it
wasn't until the 1990s when domestic
viewership breached critical mass that
its full potential could be capitalized
on the cricket authorities in India
realized television stations were
prepared to pay big money by then crowds
had declined all over the world people
were watching on television and English
Cricket an Australian cricket found that
when they played India they could sell
their television rights to these Indian
television stations for a lot of money
and that is where India if you like took
over the world game
[Music]
while the Sport's original days long
format continued to have an appeal with
long-standing fans crickets struggled to
entice new younger audiences
this pressure only intensified as the
unparalleled popularity of Mega
franchises like the NFL and the EPL
continue to proliferate
in an attempt to reinvigorate the sport
a variety of shorter formats with fewer
overs were created
England finding audiences were not
coming to Cricket Spectators were not
coming to Cricket devised a new format
of the game where only 20 overs were
bowled by each side you know shortened
the game because then you could play the
game in an English Summer started one or
two o'clock played till about seven
o'clock eight o'clock and somebody could
finish their work at five and this pop
in for two or three hours that was the
idea
England's 20 over format also known as
T20 or 2020 launched its first
professional tournaments in 2003.
the shorter format made it a much better
fit for broadcasters Sky Sports
televised eight group matches and the
entirety of finals Day live
England's T20 World Cup was a success
domestically and had proved the
potential of a more explosive version of
the game
but it would take a total disruption in
2008 to change the course of cricket and
that disrupter came in the form of the
Indian Premier League
no matter which time zone you're in over
the next 51 days it's only one time and
that is to celebrate Cricket's biggest
Festival welcome to the Vivo Indian
Premier League
[Applause]
foreign
to them that's not cricket cricket is
theater where you know you have
intellectual discussions as to where the
ball is played and so on and so forth
here they said no no you don't need all
that you want entertainment you want to
rival
what the cinema offers you what any
other form of entertainment offers you
the IPL didn't just take inspiration
from America's pre-show entertainment
and pyrotechnics it also adopted a
similar League structure where the same
teams compete every year
for the IPL they devised completely new
teams so it became Mumbai Indians owned
by one of the richest businessmen in
India composed some of them from Mumbai
composer players from around the world
or the Chennai Super Kings or you know
the Kolkata Knight Raiders so they came
up with these exotic names
you know the one difference is this is
not about a country playing Another
Country the one difference is you're
able to as a franchise attract the best
in an auction which is done prior to the
season beginning where you bid for the
best players in the world for a certain
price tag
huge for the players these days this is
a time of upheaval in sport when new
money leads promising big payouts
threaten to upend the status quo
from Saudi Arabia's controversial Liv
Gulf tour that saw golfers sign up
despite concerns over the country's
human rights record and then lose their
place from renowned PGA Tours to the
proposed European Super League
a breakaway competition in football
designed to guarantee millions of
dollars for a select few at the expense
of long-established leagues
and the IPL is no different with only 10
teams competing each under owners with
Deep Pockets it quickly attracted the
world's best players causing issues for
any other tournaments that took place
during the IPL season
player choice scheduling the kind of
proliferation of short format leagues
whilst also trying to schedule
international cricket whether it's test
match cricket the domestic game the
other International formats you know it
is quite a challenging jigsaw puzzle
the organization unofficially in charge
of putting that puzzle together is the
board of control for Cricket in India or
the BCCI
while the international cricket council
is named the global Watchman money as is
often the case Wheels power
The Humble truth here is the BCCI is the
richest body today in the world of
cricket across the globe and I think
it's purely because of the success of
IPL massively so you've got sponsorship
deals coming pouring through every
single corner of the room into the BCCI
80 percent of world Cricket's income is
provided by India in one form or the
other there's television rights there
are commercial deals when India play
abroad if you look around the stadiums
the marketing of the sponsors names are
Indian sponsors names because they have
got the rights they want their names on
television because Indians are watching
and therefore they'll sell the products
so the BCC obviously continues to ah you
know aggregate power and it stands
purely because of the type of consumers
it has at its disposal the Indian
consumer like I said uh 700 million
people watching IPL which has probably
the least number of games across any
sporting uh you know format across the
world I'm not just talking qriket I'm
talking NFL I'm talking about MLB I'm
talking EPL this has the least number of
games it has the maximum viewership
[Music]
the success of the 2022 IPL media rights
e-auction highlighted just how
successful this franchise has become in
such a short period of time
the TV and digital rights for
2022-2027 matches collectively sold for
6.2 billion dollars
this not only reaffirmed the IPL as the
leading cricket league but also made it
the second most valuable League globally
at more than 13 million dollars per
match the IPL has surpassed Global
leagues such as the EPL and the MLB and
is second only to the NFL
[Music]
Disney bagged the TV rights and a joint
venture between Paramount and Mukesh
ambani's Reliance Industries one Digital
streaming rights media companies are
constantly working hard to make sure
they get the right form of content such
that the consumer
loyalty continues to stick and grow if
you look at the case of Netflix in the
two quarters that went by they they
actually said they're going to come off
massively on their consumer numbers only
because you know they are not able to
penetrate countries like India which
require a different form of content I'm
not saying that they should go after
Cricket as a as a possible broadcasting
team they may who knows but if you get
you know sport which is universal has no
language something like a football or a
cricket
which actually attracts more consumers
given its religious following in those
specific countries I don't see a reason
why you will see more media companies
coming and you know trying to get a
partnership with the BCCI given the the
mass massive fan following across the
world
it's widely agreed upon that media is
what's propelled the values of teams to
such astronomical Heights
in the US the Big Ten a college football
conference just signed an 8 billion
dollar media rights deal
Apple signed on to a 10-year Global
broadcast deal to stream Major League
Soccer worth 250 million dollars
with so much untapped Revenue to play
for a flurry of new T20 leagues are
being created in an attempt to ride the
wave of the IPL success
South Africa have started placing our
details of the new T20 league players
are already on board a broadcast still
has been confirmed and team owners
revealed it says previous attempts at
getting an international T20 League off
the ground have failed South Africa and
the UAE are both set to launch new T20
leagues in 2023 adding to an already
packed cricketing calendar these
tournaments will put a further strain on
resources and talent especially as the
current ruling by the BCCI States no
Indian national player can take part in
other leagues unless they permanently
retire from the IPL and National cricket
the thinking here is that players
competing in other T20 tournaments will
take fans to those franchises which
could lead to tougher competition in
terms of Attraction attention and brand
value for the IPL so you've seen D20
League's uh Mushroom in Australia the
the big bash League the Caribbean
Premier League one in England and now
two new leagues being launched just
announced one in South Africa and the
other one in Dubai the Amish Cricket
Board now the fact is in all of these
leagues Indian players who have a global
fan following are not allowed to play
that's the rule and if you can't get you
know the likes of Ms dhoni or Virat
Kohli or some of the other big boys that
we have playing Cricket across the world
for the country and in the IPL League I
think you'll lose that many audiences in
an interview with Ani Sports in August
2022 the BCCI vice president Rajiv
Shukla commented on the matter our
Indian Premier League league is itself a
huge league and we cannot allow any of
our players to attach themselves to any
foreign league in any manner
the owners of the IPL teams have found a
clever way to compete with these
burgeoning leagues
buying the competition
all teams within South Africa's new T20
tournament have been bought by the
owners of IPL teams there are 10 team
owners in India all of them have tested
immense success in ipls they've seen the
evaluation go from literally nothing to
now close to 2 billion dollars per
franchise given the meteorite's
valuation when you taste that kind of
success in a limited time frame of 10 or
15 years you certainly want to
experiment as an owner a team owner and
see what this can do if other leaks take
off
now non-cricketing countries seeing the
opportunity that T20 brings are
beginning to hedge their bets
not only is the shorter format an easier
game to sell to those countries with
less understanding of the sport but the
money floating around and growing demand
for talent offers the perfect incentive
for young athletes
right now we're in the middle of a
hysterical event for Cricket Finland
because we've never hosted an
international cricket tournament before
I think from our perspective as a
non-traditional country we've been
looking at at the data that's come out
from our uh World Cup qualifier event
there are quite significant viewership
figures which have come through
purely uh from a Finnish based
viewership
um and I think looking at that in terms
of the way forward that's come about
simply because uh the game itself has
become more attractive for people to
actually come and watch it's become
something which is is more sold as a
product has more things going on for for
the viewer when they come to the ground
we've tried to sort of mirror that here
with it with a very smaller version
obviously we haven't got a 100 000
seater Stadium as they've got it or a
traditional cricket ground in in India
or in England but at the same time we
have looked at it to actually think
about how we can actually get new people
interested in the game and have somebody
at the game that is uh that is referring
to what's actually happening on the
cricket field or somebody that's never
seen a game of cricket before
for Finland a country whose own national
sport persapelo is also bat and ball
based T20 offers a potentially easy
transition for players and viewers
you only have to look at the average
salaries of persapelo and IPL athletes
to understand the opportunity here
in 2019 the highest salary for a
persaplo player was about 55 000.
that same year the ipl's top paid
cricketer Virat kohli's salary and
winnings came in at around 4 million
dollars
that's not to mention the 21 million
dollars he banked through endorsements
the opportunities that are there for
players in non-traditional countries to
actually have access to the global the
global stage whether that's IPL whether
that's another franchise somewhere else
in the world or whether that's within
the icc's global pathway events I think
that's something which has
itself only developed in the last
five to ten years every other Cricket
Board internationally is trying this
format because they think it will result
in them getting a lot of large reasons
in terms of dollars that come in and
they can in turn improve the local
infrastructure of the game in their
respective countries which they probably
can't do given the current state of
finances so it's a chicken and egg
situation if they are able to
successfully attract and Stage the first
or second season of the tournament by
attracting some world-class players and
getting adequate consumers media
companies will come and funnel those as
well
foreign now Cricket is hoping to break
into the largest Sports Market in the
world
the US
the US's Major League cricket
competition is set to launch in 2023
backed by investors such as Bollywood
Superstar Shahrukh Khan and Microsoft
chairman Satya Nadella
the following year in 2024 Los Angeles
will jointly host the T20 World Cup with
the West Indies
and there's also a bid by the ICC to
feature Cricket for the first time ever
in the Olympics which will also be in LA
in 2028
with so much interest in the sport and
its expansion investors are picking
apart the business model and exploring
ways to capitalize even further
[Music]
it has now gone to Serious Business
where large business owners across the
globe are seeing this as an opportunity
to own a franchise uh probably improve
governance uh get more independent
Sportsmen to come on the boards of these
companies and therefore attract the best
talent get sponsorships and increase the
scale and size of what they can do in
their respective franchises
sport has become business and sport is
still run and that is true Beyond
cricket and other sports but
particularly in cricket as if it's a
it's a it's a cottage industry we
haven't got off the field the sort of
leaders and administrators we need to to
run a a big industry like this an
industry that appeals to millions of
people and which can affect the the
lives of millions of people because for
them it's it's a form of entertainment
that they value
foreign
[Applause]